- [Red] So I got these,
- [Interviewer] What is that?
- I hope you don't mind.
- [Interviewer] What are they?
- What these?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
you said you have these.
- Yeah I'm growing 'em.
- [Interviewer] Growing what?
Horns?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Hair?
Your hair.
- You see the knots?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Okay, well you know,
they're like dreads.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is it?
- So I'm growin' em.
But I'm getting ready to cut 'em off too.
Because this new job
that I'm doing right now,
I'm moving in with them,
so I gotta shave all this off.
It's all got to go.
So hope this doesn't look terrible.
- [Interviewer] Are you okay?
- [Red] Okay, I was born November 11th,
1962.
On Veteran's day.
- And I was born on August 22nd
- Stop.
- 1957.
- I'm trying to explain to you,
to understand,
that I need to get that off my chest.
- You know that my mom died
on my seventh birthday.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you guys been married?
- I'll just sit here and just shut up.
- [Interviewer] No you go ahead Red.
- Go ahead, I'll be quiet.
- [Interviewer] I'll
police her a little bit.
All right, let's let Red finish.
- So any who,
if I ever get through this.
- Maybe never.
- I wouldn't have married her.
But she,
- [Interviewer] No, this is what,
this is what being married is like.
Get used to it.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Or get out now.
- So...
- That'll never happen.
(laughter)
(Red groans)
- That is my best friend.
- [Interviewer] So, you
guys aren't doing drugs,
like a lot of the people here on Skid Row.
You guys are drinking?
- We're alcoholics.
- [Interviewer] But there's no, no drugs?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] What's your,
what's your favorite drink?
- Vodka.
- [Interviewer] Vodka?
- Yeah, hers yeah.
- [Interviewer] And,
where do you guys sleep?
- East, 9th Place.
- [Interviewer] Do you have a tent there?
- No.
We sleep on the sidewalk.
- [Interviewer] Without a tent?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And where do you eat?
At the shelters?
- No usually I go to Subway,
or El Pollo Locos.
- [Interviewer] And where
do you get the money,
to pay, to pay for the food?
- I, I, I, I just look.
I'm the kind of person,
if I tell you I'm hungry.
- Do you have a lighter?
- Help me out with something to eat.
I'm gonna get food.
But when I come to you and say,
I'm not hungry,
I'm a alcoholic.
I need some money for something to drink.
That's what I'm going to do.
- [Interviewer] So, tell
me about your parents.
When you were a child.
Were...
- Well,
- [Interviewer] Your parents
in the picture or not?
- My dad
left my mom,
and me and my sister.
And I wasn't even five years old.
He went to raise another man's five kids.
Not even his own flesh and blood.
- [Interviewer] What about you guys?
- Our power got cut-off in our apartment.
And my mom went got rocks,
and put a grill over it,
and set fire to the table,
so she could cook us something to eat.
And then that man,
had enough balls to come back.
With his,
another man's son, in a public place.
Oh man, what kind of shit is that?
You're gonna come deny
your own flesh and blood.
To raise another man's kids.
And leave your own kids without.
I gotta forgive
but I can never forget.
God forgave me and my sins.
So, that means I got to give him his.
But, I'll never forget.
- [Interviewer] Red, tell
me about your childhood.
- Let me have a cigarette, asshole.
And that is,
my best friend.
- What was the question?
- [Interviewer] Your childhood.
Tell me about your parents.
- Okay.
- Now that's gonna hurt.
That's gonna hurt.
(Red murmurs)
- Please.
She is my best friend.
I care a lot about her.
Okay, so, my childhood.
My dad was kind of a deadbeat,
shit food in the refrigerator.
We had to bounce around
a little bit because
he couldn't hold his job.
And he was an alcoholic too.
And so,
that's my dad.
And,
his part in the picture
didn't last that long,
because my step-dad stepped in.
And he was an asshole too.
And so basically,
what happened there is,
I ended up the man of the house.
I'm the first son of my mom.
And, so she was very proud to have a son.
And,
so anyways, he stepped
in and said you know,
if you hurt this family on more time,
I'm taking over.
So he did.
So, he ended up my dad.
And we didn't like each for,
20 years.
His last 10 years,
he became very (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] So, last time we spoke,
you were here with Debbie.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And she
just kept interrupting,
kept interrupting.
So, you never really got
to finish your story.
- I don't remember where I left.
- [Interviewer] All
right, well I'll tell you.
I remember very well.
You were telling me how November
is this cursed month for you.
And your sister,
you were starting to tell
us the story of your sister,
who died in a car accident.
- Yeah.
(indistinct chatter)
- That's where it all started.
And, what happened right there was,
she went on a toy run.
You know the (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] The toy run is the,
motorcycling party.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- And so she went on the run right there,
and they ended up with a flat tire.
And so, they called AAA.
They had AAA.
And called and they changed the tire,
which ran across, it was
right there on Topanga Road.
And you know, PCH.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Right, and she ran across the road,
over there to take a leak in the rocks.
Rocks over there.
And she got smacked.
- [Interviewer] She what?
- She got smacked by a car.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're kidding.
- And the guy was drinkin'.
You know,
so, that's why I can't
mix drinking and driving.
Never.
So, that was the ultimate,
tragedy to the family.
'Cause that happened in '77.
And she just turned 18.
Okay, and you know,
it was the day before Thanksgiving,
and all of a sudden,
we've got a trooper knocking on the door.
You know, State Trooper.
Knocking on the door and you know,
made the claim that you know,
she died.
And, so that was a nightmare.
So, forget all about thanksgiving,
you know,
forget all about that.
There is it, you know.
And my mom tried to (indistinct),
my stepdad wouldn't
make it to the funeral.
One of my younger sisters,
she's one year older than me.
There's no way she could have made it.
But I had to go.
First time in my whole life
that I ever had a suit and tie on.
Hopefully, it's the last.
Okay, so.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so
what happened to your nose?
- I'm, okay, I work for El Nido Packing,
711 East 9th Place, right.
And I had pretty close to
100 pound box in my arms,
and I'm going down stairs.
And I lost my footing because
I was wearing size 11 shoes.
- [Interviewer] Let's see that nose.
- And,
- [Interviewer] Looks pretty bad.
Ouch.
Does it hurt?
- No, not now.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
it hurt when you do it?
- No, I got banged up pretty good.
And, so after I,
you know, I had fix the cargo.
I had to fix the cargo,
cause there's just blood all over the top.
So, we had to cut that open,
and repack it.
After everything dried up.
Ran to the bathroom,
had to wash it all down.
There was a puddle about that big.
Yeah, it was just smashed.
(Interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, noses will bleed.
- [Red] Smashed.
And I look back and I laugh.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Red] Yeah, so.
- [Interviewer] It'll heal.
So your other,
family members, your brothers and sisters.
- I haven't seen my brother,
in 35 years.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- He's three years younger than me.
I got a sister who lives
in Washington state.
I haven't seen her in 30 years.
But I have talked to her on the phone.
Yeah, I've done that.
And my other sister,
she ended up blowing.
Tammy, my second oldest sister.
She ended up blowing her brains out.
Exactly the same day that my mom died,
in my arms.
My mom passed away, and Tammy after that.
Three years later, on the same day man.
Put a bullet in her head.
You know so, it's like.
You never give up man.
For sure, just never give up.